you and a lot of people are pretty
snarky on Twitter uh sometimes to the
point of mockery derision even a bit of
if I were to say bad faith in in the
kind of mockery
um and you see it as a war like I
disagree with both you and Elon on this
Elon sees Twitter as a war zone or Lisa
saw it that way in the past
have you ever considered being nicer on
Twitter like
um as a voice that a lot of people look
up to that if if Ben Shapiro
becomes a little bit more about love
that's going to inspire a lot of people
or no this is just too fun for you the
answer is yes sure it's occurred to me
like it let's put it this way there are
a lot of tweets that actually don't go
out that I delete uh I'll say the
Twitter Twitter's new function that 30
second function is is a friend of mine
every so often I'll tweet something and
I'll it'll I'll think about it a second
I'll be like do I need to say this
probably not can you make a book
uh published after you pass away of all
the tweets that you didn't send oh no my
kids are still going to be around you
know the Legacy
um but yeah I mean sure the answer is
yes and there's a good piece of what we
would call an Orthodox Judaism this is
like he's gonna be a Muslims right now
this is like the the kind of you know be
a better person stuff I I agree with you
I agree with you and uh and yeah and I
will say that Twitter is sometimes too
much fun I try to be and I try to be at
least if not even-handed then
um equal opportunity in my derision and
I remember that during the 2016
primaries I used to post uh rather
snarky tweets about virtually all of the
candidates of Republican and Democrat uh
and uh every so often I'll still do some
of that I do think actually the amount
of snark on my Twitter feed has gone
down fairly significantly I think if you
go back a couple of years it was
probably a little more snarky uh today
I'm trying to use it a little bit more
in terms of strategy to get that
information now that doesn't mean I'm
not gonna make jokes about for example
you know Joe Biden I will make jokes
about Joe Biden he's the president of
the United States nobody else will mock
him so the entire comedic establishment
has decided they actually work for him
so the president of the United States no
matter who they are get the snark from
yes yes and and president Trump I think
is is fairly aware that he got this
knock for me as well like this when it
comes to snarking the president I'm not
going to stop it I think the president
deserves to be snarked so you're not
afraid of attacking Trump no I mean I've
I've done it before